oh my god that's the biggest fly that is
an enormous fly I know if it landed here
what you do is you go oh get it over
here because you put it there and you go
because the fly feels the pressure of
the air coming from either side so you
click it and you get it every time never
murder that fly has no idea what the
danger it's in I so hope he comes back
notice it Oh oh my god did you just
drink the fly
oh my sweet God
okay
you drunk now it's drunk I've chewed it
drink didn't realize I had any ice in
there
oh let's see let's see okay are you
ready see you ready
it's like sexy si fly just throw a
little chalk outline around it but you
didn't swallow any of it it's also there
that's why I have a good girl